hey guys welcome to another exciting
video by simply learn in this video we
bring you the top 10 computer hacks of
all time but before we begin if you're
new here and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the Subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting Tech
videos every day let's see what we have
at number 10.
from April 27 2007 estonium the European
country faced a series of cyber attacks
that lasted for weeks this happened when
the Estonian government decided to move
the bronze soldier from Talon Center to
a less prominent military cemetery
located on the city's outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down Estonian Banks online services
media Outlets broadcasters and
government bodies botnets sent massive
waves of spam and vast amounts of
automated Online requests according to
researchers the public faced DDOS
attacks there were conflicts to edit the
English language version of The Bronze
soldiers Wikipedia page as well although
there is no confirmation Russia is
believed to be behind these cyber
attacks that largely crippled the
Estonian Society let's now move on to
the next attack on December 23 2015
several parts of Ukraine witnessed a
power outage and this was not a typical
blackout it was indeed the result of a
Cyber attack Information Systems of
three energy distribution companies in
Ukraine were compromised it is the first
known Victorious Cyber attack on a power
grid it is said that here hackers send
out phishing emails to the power
companies 30 substations were Switched
Off and about 230 000 people were left
in the dark for about 1 to six hours U.S
investigators believe that russia-based
hackers were responsible for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a Cyber attack caused a
21-day shutdown of NASA computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
Jonathan James he first penetrated a U.S
Department of Defense divisions
computers and installed a back door on
its servers this allowed him to
intercept more than a thousand
government emails including the ones
containing usernames and passwords
this helped James steal a piece of NASA
software and crack the NASA computers
that support the International Space
Station
which cost the space Exploration Agency
forty one thousand dollars as systems
were shut down for three weeks he was
the first person to carry out a computer
hack against the American space agency
let's now move on to the next attack
in late November 2014 there was a leak
of confidential data from the film
studio Sony Pictures
information about Sony Pictures
employees their emails copy of the then
unreleased Sony films future
propositions and other crucial data were
leaked this Cyber attack was carried out
by a hacker group named Guardians Of
Peace so what did the hackers want well
they demanded that Sony withdrawal its
then upcoming film the interview the
movie was a comedy storyline to
assassinate the North Korean leader Kim
Jong-un Sony then decided to cancel the
film's theatrical release due to the
threats at Cinemas screening the film it
is indeed hard to trace the roots of a
Cyber attack in this case after
evaluation the U.S intelligence
officials arrived at the theory that the
attack was in a way related to the
government of North Korea however North
Korea had denied the same moving out on
to number six in December 2006 TJX the
U.S retailer company identified that
45.6 million debt and credit card
details were stolen this happened from
one of its systems over 18 months by an
unknown number of recruiters it was one
of the first largest ever cyber attacks
involving the loss of personal data as a
result banks in the affected regions had
to reissue and block thousands of
payment cards a group of hackers did
this Albert Gonzalez being The
Mastermind
the group was from Miami the place where
the TJX Heist was believed to have
originated
reports said that the TJX data breach
occurred because of weak WEP encryption
at two of its Marshall stores in Miami
next moving on to our top five let's see
what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet this
malware's motive was unlike any other
usual cyber attacks it aimed at
destructing the equipment the computers
controlled stuxnet came with a deadly
purpose of damaging Iran's nuclear
infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 Industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plan in Iran
stuxnet initially spread via Microsoft
Windows and targeted Siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
It is believed to have been silently
sabotaging Iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems it largely damaged the
centrifuges of the Iranian reactors It
is believed to be a cyber weapon created
by U.S and Israeli intelligence although
there is no documented evidence or
acceptance by either of the countries
for the same
moving on to number four in the year
2014 Home Depot was the victim of one of
the deadliest cyber attacks 56 million
payment cards were compromised along
with 53 million customer email addresses
stolen the security breach happened from
April to September 2014.
criminals were believed to have used a
third-party vendor's username and
password to enter the perimeter of the
Home Depot's Network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom-built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the U.S and
Canada
moving on to our top three as you might
be aware the PlayStation gaming system
is one of Sony's most popular products
unfortunately in April 2011 Sony
Executives witnessed abnormal activity
on the PlayStation Network
this resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million PlayStation
users accounts and prevented users of
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation Portable
consoles from accessing the service this
forced Sony to turn off the PlayStation
Network on April 20th
on May 4th Sony confirmed that
personally identifiable information from
each of the 77 million accounts had been
exposed the outage lasted 23 days Sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage in the end
Sony is believed to have invested
approximately 170 million dollars to
improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected let's now move on
to the next attack at number two in May
2017 one of the deadliest cyber attacks
took place it was known as the wannacry
ransomware attack caused by the wannacry
crypto worm the victims were the users
that used the unsupported version of
Microsoft Windows and those that hadn't
installed the new security update this
did not take place through fishing like
other attacks but through an exposed
vulnerable SMB Port the attack
originated in Asia and then eventually
spread across the globe in a day more
than 200 000 computers were infected
across 150 countries the wannacry cry
crypto worm locked the users out of the
target systems and encrypted the data
the users were asked for a ransom of 300
to 600 dollars which had to be paid via
Bitcoin to exchange the data this attack
took a toll on private and government
organizations
the attack resulted in Damages from
hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars
in a matter of a few days the emergency
patches released by Microsoft halted the
attack also the discovery of a kill
switch prevented the infected computers
from spreading the crypto worm Security
Experts and a few countries believe that
North Korea was behind this attack and
finally let's see what we have here at
number one more than two decades ago in
March 1999 the Melissa virus a
mass-milling macro virus was released it
targeted Microsoft Word and
outlook-based systems and created
considerable Network traffic Melissa
virus infected computers via email the
email would look like an important
message well yes it was fake if the
recipient opens the attachment in the
mail and downloads the document and then
opens it with Microsoft Word a virus was
released on their computers
this would then Mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victim's contact
list and then disable multiple Safeguard
features on Microsoft Word and Microsoft
Outlook this began spreading like
wildfire across the internet David L
Smith released the virus and this virus
caused nearly 80 million dollars worth
of Damages it did not steal data or
money however it caused Havoc almost 1
million email accounts were disrupted
worldwide agencies were overloaded and
some had to be shut down entirely and
internet traffic in some locations
slowed down so with that we come to the
end of this video on the top 10 hacks of
all time
do you agree with our list if you're
aware of any other great interesting
computer hacks in history do let us know
in the comments section below
thank you so much for being here and do
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to Simply learn